speaking of tom brady he's already done
more
than we've ever seen any quarterback do
and he's 43 and almost a half now
and
still going strong he had said for years
when asked how long he was going to play
10 more years
10 more years i think he had 10 years of
saying 10 more years then it settled in
on 45 and for a while i thought that was
just a distraction that he wanted to put
his ending date so far out of the future
that when he walked away no one would
see it coming because i don't think and
i know this from talking to people who
know him he would thrive or want a derek
jeter style farewell tour he doesn't
want that i think he wants to be done
and that's it and he's gone
and now that 45 is just two seasons away
and you look at how he's playing
could he play to 46 47 48 could he make
it to 50 for crying out loud
i i'm not betting against him mike i
mean
i think what we've seen this year from
him getting the buccaneers to the super
bowl is beyond amazing he's done so many
great things i i think everyone will
agree 49ers fans come on you have to
agree with this too he
tom brady is the greatest quarterback in
the history of the game perhaps the
greatest player in the history of game
with what he done and you can point to
so many great things that he's done all
the supers everything else but mike this
to me at his age to walk into a team
first time
line and carry them to the super bowl
and i i realized like he didn't make all
pro he make the pro bowl probably should
have made the pro bowl over caller
murray frankly but he didn't do that but
he still his leadership and everything
else he brought to the bucks i don't
know that any other quarterback could
have led this buccaneers team to the
super bowl you'd like to think maybe
there would have been another
quarterback or two or ten that could but
but i don't know that i know tom brady
did it and i'm astonished that he was
able to do it at his age in his first
year with this team and oh by the way
there was no off season
yeah right team right place right time
and also the right amount of time to let
it all get to the point where
after the buy a late buy that turned out
to be very good for the buccaneers win
after win after win after win from seven
and five before the buy to 7-0 afterward
trying to go 8-0 against the team that
beat them
just before their bi-weekly
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports